Season 1 of House of the Dragon is over and
now it’s time to rank the episodes.
As usual, this is my opinion and without further
ado, let’s get into it.
Number 10 - Episode 6, The Princess and the
Queen.
So even though this episode is at the bottom
of the list, that doesn’t mean it’s flat-out
bad.
It’s just, this episode had the unfortunate
circumstance of being right after a 10-year
time jump.
So every development is either a re-introduction
or throwing us into something entirely new
that doesn’t really make sense in the given
context.
The biggest rift to me is Daemon’s endpoint
in episode 5 and the starting point for this
episode.
We end with a man killing his wife, still
being a nuisance in Kingslanding, and saying
that he’s going to claim his inheritance
in getting Runestone.
For the latter, we never hear of this development
again and we never know if Daemon actually
inherited Runestone.
We actively set up a conflict between Gerald
Royce challenging Daemon in court, but nothing
comes of this.
Then Laena is now suddenly betrothed to Daemon
and they have two kids.
This is jarring to say the least given that
he just killed his last wife and is still
kind of obsessed with Rhaenyra.
So any scenes here are immediately off-putting
from how much of a disconnection we have from
where we last left off and this point in the
story.
The same thing applies to Rhaenyra’s relationship
with Ser Harwin and other minor plotlines
like Allicent’s bond with Larys and Ser
Criston.
The writers are essentially skipping over
the mid-point of development for these plotlines
to the point that it dampens the impact of
their payoff.
The deaths of Ser Harwin and Laena would have
been significantly stronger if we came to
know who they were.
Like Laena’s death in particular was well
executed, but how can we feel that bad for
her when she was only in like 3 scenes.
On a plot basis, that’s very flawed, but
there are still some good scenes here that
makes this episode better than most of the
later seasons of Game of Thrones.
Scenes like Rhaenyra’s long oner of childbirth
which brilliantly showing off Emma D’arcy’s
ability to act.
Getting to see the dragon pit and the introduction
of the new kiddies were well executed.
And the brief drama we get tied to Rhaenyra’s
kids being bastards and that complex dynamic
infecting the red keep was great but we needed
more time of that so it could breathe.
So this episode if anything would have been
significantly better if there was one before
this that handled more set-up.
Number 9 - Episode 5, We Light the Way.
This episode is tough because it’s pretty
solid up until the ending.
The ending just leaves such a sour taste in
my mouth from how sloppily executed it was
and the amount of questions that are left
standing.
I don’t think I necessarily need to go into
detail since I’ve talked about this scene
extensively on two occasions, however, I do
think I overreacted a bit in terms of Criston’s
arc as a character.
That aspect I’ve come to like more in him
trying to redeem his honor by proposing to
Rhaenyra and his overall quick mental decline.
I just wish we experienced Criston’s breakdown
through his own perspective and was more of
a rich character moment.
Instead of it being a convoluted mess of confusion
shown primarily from the perspective of the
dinner table.
Then this is also exasperated by there being
a time jump after this so any confusion you
have isn’t answered and we have to make
assumptions.
That definitely sucks and this flaw essentially
stems into the next episode in which there
were a lot of plotlines that needed more scenes.
Now since there is a big flaw, does this episode
particularly outweigh it with any great scenes?
To me, that question is kind of a no.
Every scene on average is pretty good within
the show, but not much else within this episode
really stands out to me.
Criston’s arc is the main emphasis here,
but there are two small scenes that I think
redeem it a bit that makes it better than
episode 6.
Which are Otto’s farewell to Allicent and
Viserys talking to Lyonel Strong.
Otto’s farewell is so juicily dramatic as
he shatters Allicent’s naivety and makes
her see the truth in the danger that is Rhaneyra.
It’s the first time we don’t see Otto
hold back as he brutally manipulates and scares
the shit out of his own daughter.
And the acting from both of them is stellar
along with it being in the rain that matches
the intensity of their dialogue.
And as usual Rhys Ifan’s delivery is golden.
“If Rhaenyra succeeds him war will follow,
do you understand?”
Then for Visery’s monologue, him recollecting
about his life and asking Lyonel if he was
a good king was very sweet.
Kind of brings up an interesting internal
struggle if it would have been better to be
remembered more for going to war, or having
a peaceful rule that people may not remember
as much.
Essentially solidifying Viserys as someone
who cares more about the realm than his own
ego.
An overall good episode that would have been
higher on my list if it wasn’t for the misfire
of the ending.
Number 8 - Episode 9, The Green Council.
I was honestly pretty torn between placing
this episode as number 9 or 8, however, I
think this episode just barely beats out We
Light the Way since the ending isn’t as
bad and the opening of the episode is outstanding.
That small council meeting has such a thick
layer of dread over it as we eagerly anticipate
what these leeches are going to do.
Then for everything to unfold and slowly start
to deteriorate and explode was so good.
Developments like Otto planning all this before
this meeting, Allicent freaking out about
that and their intentions, Lord Beesbury’s
death, and Westerling finally challenging
Criston made this scene consistently riveting.
It’s just too bad that the scene wasn’t
longer because I could have watched what happened
there for a very long time.
Because after this point I think the episode
loses some of its steam during the long search
for Aegon.
And that just comes down to the plot because
this plot point isn’t as interesting in
comparison to most story developments since
it’s essentially our characters wandering
around Flea Bottom.
That and were primarily following Erryk and
Arryk and it was very hard to track who was
who during their growing divide as brothers.
Like I still don’t know which Erryk is the
good one since they have the same damn name.
I think this whole portion of the episode
would have been better if we spent more time
in the red keep because I was infinitely more
intrigued by Otto being a menacing ruler and
forcing lords to change allegiances.
I think most people would agree that they’d
rather see that than listen to Mysaria drone
on about Flea Bottom or whatever in her annoying
accent that you need to turn on subtitles
for.
But I guess it’s nice we're getting some
world-building.
Then going into the ending, I think Aegon
had a simple and effective arc that allowed
us to quickly sympathize with him.
A man going from despising his existence,
not being loved, and feeling like he has no
place in this world to finally being accepted,
being loved, and gaining a sense of meaning
from becoming the king.
Surprisingly a good arc.
Then the unfortunate Rhaneys conundrum happens.
Again, I don’t think this is as bad as the
ending to episode 5 which I assume some people
will disagree on, but at least it isn’t
flat-out confusing.
Because her reasoning for not killing the
Greens at least makes sense.
It just feels like a half-thought-out moment
to try and give Rhaneys a badass event that
doesn’t even come across that way since
she kills hundreds of innocents.
So it definitely needed some re-writing, in
comparison to Criston’s scene that on top
of needing re-writes needed additional scenes
to clear up what the hell happened.
Number 7 - Episode 4, King of the Narrow Sea.
We are essentially out of the territory of
episodes that have bad aspects that weigh
them down.
For this episode, the reason why I’d put
it a bit lower in comparison to the others
is mostly the plot.
Rhaenyra’s lust-driven adventure with Daemon
and him dumping her wasn’t my favorite episodic
debacle.
Firstly, it felt a bit confusing as to Daemon’s
motivations because his intention was to soil
Rhaenyra for marriage so he could marry her
himself, thus becoming king, but that plan
is pretty ridiculous given that Viserys would
never buy that.
So then was he actually lying in that moment
to Viserys?
Did Daemon improvise that plan to hide the
fact that he almost fell in love with Rhaenyra,
but stopped himself?
Although in episode 7, he says that he spared
Rhaenyra in that moment, so that would back
up his plan of ruining her image to marry
her himself.
So yeah, that felt a little convoluted to
say the least but I still really enjoy the
dynamic between Rhaenyra and Daemon and their
overall night out in Kingslanding was cool.
That and the writers paralleled this fun adventure
with Allicent’s relationship with Viserys
which was devoid of life and enjoyment.
This then leads to a romantic sex scene with
Ser Criston Cole, which at first I loved,
but now that I hate Ser Criston it makes me
upset seeing this.
That doesn’t hurt the quality of the episode,
it just makes me salty.
Ironically out of all this spicy conflict,
the thing that intrigued me the most was Otto
having to tell Viserys the hard truth about
Rhaneyra.
That made for a crazily awkward scene and
seeing Otto struggle to deliver the news was
so pleasing because we’ve never seen him
this worried before.
Then Rhaenyra convincing Viserys to remove
Otto as hand, made for a great ending to the
episode.
Those were my favorite aspects and the rest
was alright.
So in comparison to the other episodes that
have great plot points, I’m going to like
those a bit more.
Number 6 - Episode 1, The Heirs of the Dragon.
Normally the first episode for different shows
tends to skew towards one of the lesser episodes
since they are tasked with having to do a
lot of set-up and exposition.
But The Heirs of the Dragon doesn’t do this.
Only in the opening scene do we get exposition,
and to be fair, it’s kind of necessary to
establish where we are in the history of Westeros.
After this though, the writers essentially
plant us right into an already existing world
and do very little exposition.
They seamlessly blend us into this narrative
and allow the audience to learn who the characters
are by seeing them react to different forms
of conflict.
No expository dialogue is needed when each
character is being molded by different obstacles
that test them.
Like right away Viserys is tested by the birth
complications of his new child and then having
to deal with succession issues after the death
of his wife.
Daemon trying to find some form of purpose
and dealing with the reality of not being
the heir anymore.
Rhaneyra navigating through all those obstacles
while taking on the responsibility of becoming
the new heir.
And different side characters briefly cutting
in in each scene to try and sway the main
characters’ minds with their own wants and
wishes.
The show quickly establishes and fully develops
each of its main characters as we are thrown
into an engaging story with outstanding conflict.
Like the birth scene was so horrific and tragic
that it really sets the tone for the story
to come.
Not to mention that a lot of the dialogue
scenes were all very interesting.
Especially when the topic of succession comes
up and we see Viserys break down and everyone
trying to influence him for their own benefit.
Then there’s also a fun tournament with
jousting to add some spectacle into the episode,
so overall this opening episode is well-balanced
and acts as a perfect introduction to House
of the Dragon.
Number 5 - Episode 2, The Rogue Prince.
This may be an unpopular opinion, but I like
The Rogue Prince a little more than the first
episode.
This episode opens immediately with a haunting
feeling as we first see what the Crabfeeder
is doing.
This both gives us some great imagery, on
top of it giving what Corlys has to say some
weight because before this we didn’t really
know what was happening in the stepstones.
So quickly and efficiently this opening makes
us excited for this upcoming conflict.
This then leads into a small council meeting
and in this scene we see Rhaenyra finally
speak out, which essentially teases her independent
attitude and that leader quality is starting
to break through.
Not only does she have these triumphant character
moments, but we also break Rhaenyra down in
two separate scenes where she deals with the
loss of her mother and Viserys having to move
on and find a new wife.
Each of these scenes hits a beautiful emotional
depth that absorbs the audience with Milly’s
entrancing performance.
This is to me, what sold the actress so well.
These small character moments where they simply
talk to one another and go through a vast
array of emotions drips with so much intrigue.
These scenes are also imbued with a great
point of conflict in which Viserys has to
deal with having to find a new wife.
This dynamic has a lot of depth because every
character has a stake in it and can add something
new.
Like everyone having their own mischievous
motivations and seeing Viserys go along with
some of them like talking with Laena was funny.
Then this isn’t even mentioning the best
part, which is the tense showdown at Dragonstone
between Otto and Daemon.
The amount of tension within this scene was
so palpable.
From the music slowly building up, the fog
obstructing the sun and creating a tense atmosphere,
how unpredictable Daemon is, and Caraxes showing
up made this scene so fun to watch.
Then it takes an unpredictable turn where
Rhaneyra shows up to solve the confrontation
without any bloodshed, thus acting as her
big moment.
And this moment also unlocks her theme that
she essentially earns here, and Rhaneyra’s
theme is probably my favorite throughout the
entire show.
The Rogue Prince is pretty great through and
through and even the cinematography is at
its best in my opinion.
Number 4 - Episode 3, Second of his Name.
Initially, I wasn’t a huge fan of the first
half of the episode, but I’ve come to really
like the journeys that both Rhaenyra and Viserys
go on.
The parallels to how they both treat their
anguishes were interesting since Rhaenyra
chooses to run away and be rebellious while
Viserys chooses to drown himself in wine.
Seeing him grapple with the annoyance of politicking
and wondering if he made the right decision
to make Rhaenyra his heir allows us to see
Viserys without any barriers.
Kings are always really reserved, but here,
he’s pouring out so many emotions that we
are allowed to witness and feast on.
Like the bonfire in particular was the peak
of the episode in my opinion because of this.
Then Rhaneyra also boils over to a degree
and lets out all of her anger while killing
the boar.
She’s so overcome with the responsibilities
of growing up, having to marry, and being
a pawn for her father in terms of politics
that it’s driving her crazy.
So her showing back up to the camp drenched
in blood makes her seem like a badass and
commands respect.
I also like the small detail of Ser Harwin
being turned on by that.
Kind of foreshadowing the future.
This dual journey has some great character
development and even the resolution afterward
in Kingslanding was pretty touching.
Viserys deciding to let Rhaneyra choose who
to marry was a great compromise, but yet again,
that’s not necessarily a good choice to
make as a king.
Then we have the stepstones conflict.
To me, the best aspect of this battle is easily
Daemon Targaryen.
This was a great showcase for the man where
he risks everything to prove himself and even
turns down help from his brother.
The rush he makes was some intense action
and I hope people have moved away from the
arrow controversy.
Because relax, the man still gets hit like
3 times.
My only issue with this portion of the episode
is the fact that it doesn’t really last
that long.
The actual battle only lasts like 2 minutes
and then it quickly ends once Daemon walks
out with the Crabfeeder’s corpse.
It gives off a bit of an anticlimactic feeling
and if they had more impressive/longer takes
of action following our heroes then this episode
would maybe crack my top 3 for this season.
But it’s still pretty good and acts as a
fun final sequence to an already great episode.
Number 3 - Episode 10, The Black Queen.
Some people may feel compelled to put this
episode at number 1, because of the insane
final scene with Vagar, but I think this finale
has a bit too much set-up.
And that’s in regards to wartime preparations.
It’s nice to see, but it’s not something
that you’d expect within a finale that’s
normally packed with a lot of payoff.
Which the payoff we do get is amazing.
Rhaenyra having a miscarriage was extremely
uncomfortable and drastically increased the
tension at the beginning of the episode, Rhaenyra
becoming queen was immensely uplifted by Ramin
Djawadi’s wonderful score, Corlys finally
allying himself with Rhaneyra was so satisfying
when his theme played, and the death of Lucerys
was batshit insanity and had some of the best
action and tension build-up we’ve ever seen.
If the episode was just these scenes with
maybe 1 set-up scene cut out or even just
the ending 10-minute sequence on repeat, then
It would be hard to not put this episode at
number 1.
But since there is a lot of round-table discussions
within the episode, it slows down the fast
and fun pace.
Cutting out one of the set-up scenes could
be better to keep the pace moving more quickly,
but it’s hard to say that since they are
needed and are still good.
This is obviously a minor issue and these
are the things I need to address when the
top 3 episodes are so close in quality.
I can honestly argue why this episode and
the next two could be number 1 and at the
end of the day it will come down to opinion.
One thing that we can all agree on though
is how perfect the ending of the season is.
Aemond chasing Lucerys on Vagar was so intense
given the size difference and the setting
of the scene.
Hiding away this massive threat in the thundering
clouds was terrifying and the action was perfectly
presented by not hiding the VFX in terrible
lighting conditions.
The fact that we can follow the action with
ease is refreshing and it never breaks our
immersion. 10 minutes of pure adrenaline and
this scene alone carries the episode.
Number 2 - Episode 7, Driftmark.
When this episode was released it was my favorite
and it almost retained that spot.
The reason it was there in the first place
is that this episode has a perfect collection
of scenes.
Nothing feels out of place, there’s no downbeat,
and it just keeps getting better.
The episode opens strong with an ensemble
of characters interacting with each other.
I tend to love these scenes because of how
much depth is here and the number of small
interactions that happens between every character.
Everyone has a moment to shine here and the
writers efficiently set up certain dynamics
that will be integral later on.
Then we have an engrossing debate between
Rhaenys and Corlys.
Their motivations perfectly contrast with
each other which allows for some great dialogue.
Two lines in this scene are even quoted in
the trailer.
And then, we have Rhanerya and Daemon on the
beach.
Now I like the writing of this scene, it’s
just that, due to the dark lighting, we can’t
really see their reactions that well.
Kind of feels like a hindrance in an otherwise
integral scene between these two characters
who are getting emotional, but that’s the
only small flaw within this episode.
This leads into Aemond taming Vagar and this
was a great display of awe-inspiring scale.
The action as Aemond tries to desperately
hold on was so gripping.
This is followed by Aemond having a violent
confrontation with Rhaenyra’s children,
which I honestly did not know how that scene
was going to play out.
So when Aemond loses an eye I was genuinely
surprised.
This sets up the best scene of the episode
in which Allicent demands justice for that.
So many aspects about this scene are amazing.
We have Viserys desperately trying to keep
everyone at bay, the awkward silence as everyone
acknowledges the truth about Rhaenrya’s
children, the harsh back-and-forth dialogue,
and the explosive ending as Allicent rushes
Rhaenyra with Viserys’ dagger.
Truly a great climax and somehow the episode
doesn’t end here and ends with a crazy encore
of Laenor’s fake-out death.
Which even that scene has some impressive
writing in that the writers lead you to believe
that Laenor actually dies, but doesn’t and
gets a happy ending.
This episode is flat-out stacked and has great
character work, action, plot twists, love,
and even Otto Hightower gets reinstated as
hand.
Easily top 2 worthy and is really close to
being in my top spot.
But the next episode has something very special
about it.
Number 1 - Episode 8, The Lord of the Tides.
Yeah, you know why this episode is at number
1.
The last supper is easily the best scene in
the season and is a pure rush of happiness
every time I watch it.
I don’t know how many people here watch
Rick and Morty, but I’m like the Rick who’s
held prisoner as they make him watch the same
happy scene over and over to farm Serotonin,
but for me, that scene on replay is Viserys
smiling.
It’s such a purely wholesome moment that
I couldn’t help but shed a tear when first
watching it.
Throughout the entire season, we come to love
Viserys and the tragedy of his entire bodily
decay makes us feel so bad for him.
So seeing this last moment in which he gets
to witness his family be happy one more time
is extremely precious and is not something
I was expecting to come out of this dark show.
That and the rest of this scene is still great
in which he reveals his face to everyone and
gives a heartwarming speech.
Along with Rhaenyra trying to reconcile with
Allicent.
This is the perfect example of the calm before
the storm.
Then for the rest of the episode, there’s
really no down moment.
Rhaenyra and Daemon visit Viserys while the
man is in agony, Allicent having to deal with
a handmaid getting raped by Aegon which in
particular was a great showcase for the handmaid
actor in terms of acting, Allicent roasting
Aegon and him being douche, Rhaenyra awkwardly
meeting up with Rhaenys after killing her
son, Viserys’ makeup routine, and some other
quick scenes that are all equally intriguing.
However, this wouldn’t be in my number one
spot without another standout scene, which
is the throne room debate for the succession
of Driftmark.
Throughout this entire scene, you know this
hearing is rigged in Vaemond’s favor so
you have no idea how Rhaenyra will come out
of this situation on top and I assumed she
wouldn’t.
So to have Vizzy T show up like an absolute
legend works as an excellent twist and it’s
also severely uplifted by Ramin Djawadi going
ham on the score.
And I also love the fact that the director
draws this moment out so much by having Viserys
slowly walk across the entire throne room.
Really emphasizing how much of an impressive
feat this is.
Then Vaemond explodes and Daemon removes his
head.
So overall great escalation in terms of plot
points and twists within this scene and it
just keeps getting better as you go through
it.
With this shocking death, triumphant moment
for Viserys, one of the most heartwarming
moments in Game of Thrones history, and a
collection of solid scenes in between those
bangers makes this a GOATED episode of House
of the dragon.
Thank you for watching and let me know in
the comments what your ranking would be.